OK.
Now, I don't want to worry people unnecessarily,
but we need to be correctly concerned, correctly
concerned that national polls have tightened.
Donald Trump is closer now to Joe Biden in
national polling than he has been since May,
which was almost five months ago.
These polls, importantly, do not yet take
into account the effect of the first debate.
This is still all predebate polling, but we
have to acknowledge that it is looking less
good for Joe Biden today than it was looking
last month and the month before and the month
before that.
And if we don't vote, if we don't all vote,
we may all be devastated on November 4th.
So looking at the average of recent national
polling from Real Clear Politics right now,
Joe Biden's average lead is six point one.
Now, on September 11th, it was eight.
And on July 27, that was nine point three.
And on June twenty third, it was ten point
two.
So this is not the right trend.
Now, let's let's look at it in a different
way, in chart form.
So, again, June twenty third.
Biden's up ten point two in the month.
That follows by July 27.
Biden's lead has dropped by just about a point
to nine point three.
By September 11th.
Biden's lead has dropped to eight.
Another roughly point in a half.
And then between September 11th and today,
Joe Biden's lead dropped one point nine points
on average.
This is not good.
When you see a lead go from ten point two
to six point one in a few months.
That's a 40 percent shrinkage of the lead.
It's not small.
There are also some recent polls that are
not exactly giving me too much comfort.
I've highlighted some of them here on this
image, which we're showing our TV audience.
A recent national poll has Biden only up by
two.
That's the lowest we've seen in a high rated
national poll for a while in Wisconsin.
Joe Biden is only up by two.
That's a state he had been leading by more
on average.
Biden is still winning, but seeing a poll
in which Biden's only up two is not exactly
encouraging.
North Carolina recent poll has Trump ahead
after many polls had Biden ahead.
So this is not panic.
Oh, no.
But it is this is not nearly over.
None of us should think it is.
And none of the polls sort of price in voter
suppression, voter intimidation, whatever
Donald Trump may be able to achieve through
the courts to stop the counting of absentee
ballots.
None of that is even in the polls.
There are also some good indicators in the
last couple of days as an exact example.
There is a poll out of North Carolina for
the Senate.
Remember that in North Carolina, you have
incumbent Republican Thom Tillis defending
his seat against Democratic challenger Cal
Cunningham.
There's a new poll that has Cal Cunningham,
the chance challenger, up six in North Carolina.
That's great.
Pull out of Georgia where Democratic giant
challenger John USCIRF is up by one against
the incumbent Republican Senator Perdue.
Forget what his first name is, Senator Perdue
in Georgia.
That's very, very good.
But it is not an exaggeration when I say every
race, every state has to be fought for.
Figure out how you will vote if you're interested
in voting absentee.
Go to vote dot org slash absentee hyphen ballot
or just search Google for vote dawg.
Absentee ballot.
It will take you to a page you put in your
address.
It tells you how you and your state request
an absentee ballot.
It's not too late if you want to vote early.
You go to Google, you type in vote, dawg.
Early voting.
The first result is a page telling you how
to vote early in your city or town or locality.
Have a plan.
We cannot assume anything.
And when you look at the you know, whenever
I do this, I get e-mails from people saying,
David, you are do your gaslighting.
It's reverse gaslighting.
I don't know what that means.
Gaslighting, his gaslighting, your gaslighting,
people into thinking it's close so that people
will vote no.
I am accurately telling you that Joe Biden's
lead in the national polls has shrunk from
10 to nine to eight to 76 over the last five
months.
Now, you can say six is still plenty enough
to win.
Well, maybe, but what if six becomes five?
And then you lose another two points because
of suppression.
And Biden wins the popular vote by three,
but loses electorally.
Then what was should I have shut up?
Come on, guys.
OK, let's be responsible.
We've all got to see the data.
We've all got
to
have a
plan here.